[Music]
the global Elite are gathering at the
world economic Forum in Davos
Switzerland it's the annual meeting's
first winter event in three years and
the ski Town attracts CEOs billionaires
and celebrities for a week of
discussions on income inequality climate
change and so much more now this year's
theme cooperation in a fragmented world
but the event does often draw a
criticism for attracting the ultra Rich
who pontificate about global issues
without really committing to fixing them
your inaction is fueling the Flames by
the hour show me the money talk is cheap
it turns out that nobody is as generous
with their actual dollars as they are
with their pledges in their press
release we can talk for a very long time
about all these stupid philanthropy
schemes we can invite Bono once more but
come on it's we got to be talking about
Texas that's it taxes taxes taxes all
the rest in my opinion one area where we
might see some movement is on the
breakdown of panels during the last
World economic Forum a third of the
panels were devoted specifically to ESG
and the use of words like
environmentalism in those Davos press
releases has actually tripled since
2014. sometimes who's not there is more
interesting than who is former president
Donald Trump is not attending nor is
current President Joe Biden and
embattled crypto entrepreneur SPF is
obviously out but there will be plenty
of panels on the future of digital
currency so follow a quick take on all
social platforms to get our updates on
the world economic Forum on the ground
in Davos
foreign